jamison how you feeling I'm feeling good
I'm alive and well over here okay well
there were there were some concerns
though after that ball came off that bad
of you know if you were going to be able
to stay in the game well okay take me
through the bat you you release the
pitch and then what happened yeah well I
remember I was behind in the count 2 and
0 so I'm looking to throw a strike and
get back in the count and I throw two
seam fastball which kind of runs a
little bit and I remember trying to
start it outside and I remember watching
it to start running right over the
middle of the plate and whenever that
happens as a fishery time kind of slows
down a little bit and so whatever curse
words I say in my head as I see that
thing going for the plate and then you
know kind of an immediate reaction when
I saw it coming at me to try to turn as
quick as I could but there's not much
you can do it's coming 105 so next thing
I knew I was on the ground how scary it
was there's pain there's the sound of it
what what are you thinking at the time
um I remember laying there on the ground
thinking I was aware of what happened
never lost consciousness or anything and
you know I remember thinking that i know
of smoked and i thought it should hurt a
little worse than it did I was kind of
waiting for it to hurt sometimes you
know I've been hitting other areas where
you know it takes second start singing
or sixty seconds start hurting I'm
wiggling my hands with my feet nothing
really hurts I don't know I got lucky
and then your parents are there watching
this yeah parents were watching I think
my girlfriend was crying sis I told them
after that you know same God I think it
looks scarier than it actually was you
know I understand why people would think
it looks scary and I know people have
that reaction but I really am hey okay
I'm just fine what is concussion
protocol on the mound um when they ran
out there
you know it's there stabilize my head or
asking me it was simple I mean to me
simple questions but where are we what
teams pitching against who is this you
know doctors you know asked me to
remember words repeat words back to them
five words in a row remember a number
four pete him backwards that they listed
to me and then you know once I passed
all that on the mound in between innings
they had me see dr. down in the tunnel
real quick that's why it was my turn to
bat I was going up there so put on my
daddy gloves and then every day since
you know I think they're going to
monitor me and I got some more tests
yesterday balanced tests more numbers
and memory tests and everything's
checking out is no headaches no residual
effects what was more painful getting
hit in the head or moving into a new
apartment probably the new apartment
because I'm tan 300 bucks a month for
parking here and it's like a two or
three block walk from my parking lot so
I'm just walking through downtown sits
for her people asking me how my head
stealing with my arms and for stuff wait
nobody wanted to help you know I never
actually got an offer but these fit
three people are really nice and will
say that did you have a headache when
you woke up yesterday morning ah not
really um woke up and you know maybe a
little bit of a headache but once I got
some food in me and some fresh air it
went away and I went to the park can I
went through my day played catch just
fine woke up today feeling extremely
normal we had fun with your name
yesterday because we even asked the
Pirates we said is it thi anh thi oanh
is a Talon and they said that you sort
of answered to any of those yeah I'm
just gonna say those three right there
or not the worst pronunciations you can
do tyonne is correct at the time yonas
but uh early years we've become pretty
insensitive that people mispronouncing
it my dad uses talent for work
at all be a pirates pitcher Jameson
Taillon or talent is joining us here the
possibility of wearing protective gear
for a pitcher a helmet could you ever
see something like that on the mound um
yeah I know they have the prototypes now
I remember when spring training mark
Morrison and Jared used to her pitchers
were trying to mount and checking them
out and interviews with them and stuff I
don't know i think the prototypes got a
little ways to go I don't know if it's I
mean for my case it would have helped me
you know there's an empty space in the
back where I got hit so I'm out of luck
there but it protects some important
areas i think they've got work to do but
you know i think something probably has
to be done I mean you look at hitters
there's 60 feet away also and they're
wearing protective gear and there I
can't imagine a hit or not wearing it so
you know we're in just as much danger
ball doesn't come at us is more but when
it does as much but when it does it's
trampoline effect off that bad and it's
usually coming back harder so i think
i'd like to see something be done I just
really don't know what were you out of
position fielding like if you were in
position curt schilling joined us
yesterday and he said that kids are not
being taught to be in good position to
field these comebackers what do you make
of that um no I mean first off I'm not
really too keen on watching the replay
of it so I'm not a hundred percent sure
but yeah I mean obviously I can catch it
so I wasn't in the greatest position
apparently but uh I don't know I think
everyone's different with their
mechanics you can't teach everyone
exactly to throw the same way at the
same time if I understand and they're
ready to field it with my glove and my
hip I don't think I get my club up in
time you know so fast I mean it was 105
off the bat there's really not much you
can do except hope you get out of the
way I hope you get lucky but I don't
know
what you could do and pitchers fielding
practice to help with that we are to get
like soft rag balls smoked at us and
stuff and missing training but you can't
really practice you know the heat of the
moment you're in a game you don't expect
that to come back at you so hello wish I
would fit in a little better but at the
same time there's really not much you
can do when it's coming back at ya it
might have hit you in the face as quick
as that was coming back if you weren't
turned to the side but I also remember
there was another shot up the middle
like the reaction from you I don't know
if you remember it but there was another
ball that went up the middle after this
and it almost looked like you jumped a
little bit more because you thought
here's another one being smoked at me or
do you normally react that way man I'm
not used to having that he might drive
stitch working me but yeah that was
actually a pretty decent pitch to Ryan
Braun that second that second one I came
back having to be smoked here right over
my head my catcher came out so my
reaction was like asking me if I'm if
I'm all right I from shaking up
permanent but yeah that one got a little
too close for comfort too well jameson
good luck with the move and good luck in
your next star i think you're ready to
go sunday yep sunday afternoon well good
luck and get your glove up all right
yeah thanks for having all right my best
sorry the Dan Patrick show weekday
mornings on audience